house of the dragon is the new game of
thrones prequel show it's set 200 years
before game of thrones and it's about
the targaryen family daenerys
targaryen's ancestors back when they
ruled westeros at the height of their
power this is a story of ambition and
politics betrayal and revenge dragons
and a lot of really angry blonde people
the show is based on a book called fire
and blood by george martin george
co-created this show with ryan condell
and they say it's a faithful adaptation
of the book george has a nickname for
house of the dragon he calls it hot d
there are a bunch of new trailers and
interviews out for hot d so what do they
reveal and what can we expect from the
new show this video has no spoilers just
introduces the characters and world
so quick history the targaryens are the
royal dynasty of westeros but originally
the targaryens came from valyria the old
empire of the dragonlords in the east
valyria was destroyed in the mysterious
doom of valyria and the targaryens were
the only dragon riders to survive cause
the targaryens had already left valyria
and settled on dragonstone an island off
westeros aegon targaryen with his sister
wives and their dragons conquered the
seven kingdoms forged the iron throne
and became the first king of westeros
after him was king aeneas then king
maegor then king jaehaerys and in house
of the dragon the king is viserys
targaryen
the basic story in hot d is that king
viserys wants his daughter princess
rhaenyra to take the throne and rule
after him but some people have other
plans for the throne including the
king's brother daemon and the king's
hand otto and otto's daughter alicent
but this conflict builds up slowly with
tensions rising over years and years so
hot d occasionally jumps forward in time
several years to show how the politics
and relationships gradually change
alicent and rhaenyra are played by
different actors as they age it's like
in the crown co-creator ryan condell
said this is a generational war and the
time span lets us fully understand these
characters and their history before the
first sword stroke falls
so viserys targaryen is king and he
inherited a peaceful and prosperous
realm from jaehaerys so viserys's reign
became the apex of targaryen power and
wealth that's reflected in the size of
the iron throne in hotd it's bigger and
grander compared to how it looks in game
of thrones the new design is also closer
to how the throne is described in the
books as a huge monstrosity of metal
forged from the swords of king aegon's
enemies
in game of thrones dragons are almost
extinct but in hot d the targaryens have
lots of dragons and that's how they
dominate westeros dragons are weapons of
mass destruction they're like the
nuclear bombs of this world and since
only the targaryens have dragons no one
can mess with them when viserys was
younger he rode the dragon bellerion the
biggest and baddest targaryen dragon but
balerion soon died of old age and
viserys hasn't ridden a dragon since in
a trailer he calls dragons a power man
should never have trifled with like
they're too dangerous to be controlled
cause king viserys is a man of peace he
just wants everyone to get along and
have a good time so he hosts feasts and
balls and tournaments he's popular with
lords and common folk viserys is a good
man but being a good man doesn't make
you a good king and times of peace can
sow the seeds of war
in a trailer viserys describes a dream
of his heir and the throne and of
dragons in the books many targaryens
have prophetic dragon dreams that can
tell the future but often these dreams
are misinterpreted and lead to the
dreamers downfall aemon targaryen says
that his brothers once dreamed of
dragons and those dreams killed them
every one
dragon dreams can be a metaphor for
ambition and the dangers of ambition
viserys's actor paddy considine says
that viserys has an ego and he wants a
legacy there is a dragon in him
so viserys is a complicated guy author
george martin said he's impressed with
considering's performance giving viserys
a tragic majesty that he never had in
the books
one of the biggest problems for viserys
is his brother prince daemon targaryen
daemon is like the opposite of viserys
because while viserys is peaceful daemon
is violent and impulsive actor matt
smith said damon is there to cause chaos
and piss people off daemon rides the red
dragon karaxis called the blood worm and
daemon's personality is reflected in his
dragon's personality karaxis is like a
huge rabid dog volatile and chaotic
there are at least 17 dragons in this
story and the showrunners say we'll meet
9 of them in season 1. each dragon has a
distinct personality colour and look
some of them are bearded like tropical
lizards karaxis is apparently a deformed
dragon with a super long neck and extra
wings on his hind legs these unique
designs contrast with the dragons in
game of thrones which were almost
impossible to tell apart despite their
colourful descriptions in the books
prince daemon is a great warrior he
wields the legendary valyrian steel
sword dark sister once used by queen
visenya and used by king maegor the
cruel
in the trailers we see daemon leading
the city watch of king's landing called
the gold cloaks we saw the gold cloaks
in game of thrones betraying ned in
season one and buying crab aphrodisiacs
in season seven cause daemon is
commander of the city watch and he's the
one who first gave the watch their gold
cloaks and better armor so daemon is why
they're now called gold cloaks daemon
gets real enthusiastic about law
enforcement especially the part where
you cut body parts off criminals as
commander of the watch he's known as the
prince of the city or lord flee bottom
daemon has an estranged wife called raya
royce who he hates and calls his bronze
[ __ ]
damon considers himself heir to the
throne after viserys but viserys doesn't
want him on the throne because he's such
a loose cannon daemon does sometimes
seem like just a violent villainous
[ __ ] but there are layers to him and
sensitivity deep down despite their
differences daemon and viserys love each
other and what daemon really wants is
approval and recognition from his
brother the books say that daemon is a
hero and a villain a rogue prince made
of both light and darkness
princess rhaenyra targaryen is viserys's
beloved only child and he wants her to
inherit his throne he keeps her by his
side a council so she can learn politics
rhaenyra is precocious beautiful and
popular at court singers call her the
realms delight rhaenyra has been a
dragon rider since age seven bonded with
the yellow dragon cyrax we can see that
targaryens now use saddles to ride their
dragons which looks a lot more
comfortable than daenerys did clinging
to drogon's scaly back in game of
thrones in hot d the dragons are kept at
this building called the dragon pit and
there's tradition around dragon eggs
baby targaryens often have dragon eggs
put in their cribs so that they bond
with the dragons that hatch from them
the targaryens have close relationships
with their dragons possibly too close
historically but rhaenyra has that
old-school targaryen fiery personality
her actor emma darcy says rhaenyra has
to learn when to dampen that fire and
when to trust it rhaenyra has
similarities to daenerys you can also
compare rhaenyra to arya with her
rebellious and cheeky spirit and her
conflict against society's gender roles
in the patriarchal world of westeros
many lords don't want a woman on the
throne there's never been a female ruler
of westeros and the rules of succession
prefer men to women so rhaenyra feels a
constant battle with what it means to be
a woman and how her gender clashes with
her political power which is a similar
theme to cersei's story
rhaenyra's best friend is alison
hightower the daughter of the hand of
the king otto hightower while rhaenyra
is rebellious alicent tends to follow
the rules and do what's expected of a
noble lady kinda like sansa stark in hot
d alison and rhaenyra grow up together
at court and they're super close like
siblings which is a change from the
books in the books alicent is older than
rhaenyra and we don't know much about
her childhood the book fire and blood
gives only a broad summary of these
events so it's up to the show hot d to
create much of the detail of these
relationships and personalities
alison came to court with her father
otto hightower as hand of the king otto
is the second most powerful person in
westeros like how ned stark and tywin
lannister were hand of the king in game
of thrones
otto's family the hightowers are one of
the oldest and richest houses in
westeros they rule the city of old town
home of the maesters of the citadel and
of the high septon of the faith of the
seven the hightowers tend to avoid war
and gain power through trade and
politics in hot d the lord of old town
is hobert hightower he rules the city
while his brother otto is at court as
hand of the king otto is a smart
strategic politician a pragmatist and a
manipulator he's proud ambitious and
ruthless but he also struggles with his
decisions otto loves his daughter
allison but they don't communicate well
and their relationship is complicated by
politics
otto hates prince daemon and wants to
prevent him having power so otto and
daemon are always competing for
influence over king viserys as well as
the high towers another important family
is house velaryon led by lord corliss
the sea snake
like the targaryens the valarions
originally came from valyria in the east
but unlike the targaryens the velaryons
aren't dragon riders instead they love
sailing and have a powerful fleet of
ships they're based on driftmark an
island near dragonstone and king's
landing and they've long been close
allies of the targaryens ruling the seas
while the targaryens on their dragons
rule the skies
lord corliss velaryon is a famous
adventurer and explorer he's sailed to
far distant places like carth yiti and
asshai
by trading with these exotic places
corlis has made the velaryons the
richest family in westeros even richer
than the lannisters and hightowers
corliss has seen the world and made a
fortune but he's still not satisfied
corliss has great ambitions for his
family
in hot d corliss and his family are
black which is a change from the books
in the books the velaryons look much
like the targaryens because the two
families have been marrying each other
for generations the targaryens like to
keep their valyrian dragon blood in the
family so when they don't marry a
velaryon they usually marry their sister
so the targaryens and velaryons in the
books are one big incestuous family of
inbred blondes while in hot d they've
changed the look but the velaryons still
have silver hair indicating the valyrian
blood that they share with the
targaryens
after corliss's voyages across the world
he got married to princess rhaenys
targaryen
rhaenys is a cousin of viserys and
daemon rhaenys's mother was a baratheon
so in the books rhaenys has black hair
rhaenys is fierce and fearless proud
smart and capable she's been a dragon
rider since she was 13 writing melis the
red queen when rhaenys married corliss
she arrived at the wedding on dragonback
corliss said i came back from the ends
of the earth for you and rainey said we
can go back to the ends of the earth
together but i'll get there first as
i'll be flying
rhaenys and corliss have a deep love and
one of the more healthy relationships in
the story but rhaenys and corliss also
have ambition and resentment because
rhaenys was the firstborn child of king
jaehaerys's firstborn son so back in the
day many people saw rhaenys as the
rightful heir to the throne but male
rulers are preferred over women so king
jaehaerys repeatedly passed over rhaenys
to make his second son balon and then
balon's son viserys the heir instead
so rhaenys is called the queen who never
was she and corliss feel that her
birthright and her children's birthright
was taken from her and this injustice
hasn't been forgotten
corliss and rhaenys have two children
lena and lenore velaryon lena is fiery
and adventurous like her parents and she
rides vega the biggest and oldest dragon
alive leno rides the splendid grey and
white dragon sea smoke
so those are the three important
families in house of the dragon the
targaryens with king viserys his
daughter rhaenyra and brother daemon the
hightowers with otto and his daughter
allison and the velaryons with corlis
his wife rhaenys and their kids elena
and lenore but there are a few other
important characters at court kristin
cole is not a prince or a lord from a
great house he's the son of a steward
but he is a talented fighter and he's
dangerously attractive a favorite of all
the ladies at court
missouria is a woman from a brothel in
lease in the books she's described as a
very pale older woman sometimes called
misery the white worm
mazzaria is a lover and trusted
confidant of prince daemon in hot day
she's described as a survivor with
street smarts and ambition
lionel strong is the lord of harrenhal
that giant half-ruined castle in the
riverlands lionel serves on king
viserys's council as the master of laws
he's a big man with a reputation as a
warrior and some people assume that he's
a dumb brute but lionel is very
intelligent having studied at the
citadel he brings his sons harwan break
bones and larys the clubfoot to court
this guy is grand maester melos he
advises the king as representative of
the citadel of the maesters like grand
maester pycelle did in game of thrones
melos is described as a voice for peace
urging calm and compromise and he's a
trusted friend of king viserys
maesters are meant to be unbiased
servants working for the good of the
realm but some characters in the books
don't trust the maesters tyrion says the
gods only know who they're conspiring
with or what they mix into their potions
another character says they could be
twisting the words of the letters that
they write and read for their lords in
book five this guy marwyn claims that
for centuries the maesters have secretly
worked against the targaryens to kill
off all their dragons
there's no proof of any of this in the
books and barwin is kind of a crazy
conspiracy theorist but if we look
closely hot d may have hints of the
maesters manipulating politics
ultimately it's the maesters who write
the history books and in fire and blood
author george martin plays with the idea
of bias in historical sources because
the main game of thrones books are
novels told from the point of view of
the characters in the moment but fire
and blood is different it's a fictional
history book written by an in-world
historian called archmaester gildane
gildane wrote fire and blood years after
the events he's describing so he relies
on historical sources that are sometimes
contradictory two of his main sources
for the story of hot d a recepton called
eustace and a dwarf jester called
mushroom while eustace's version of the
story is very proper and straightforward
mushroom's version is full of bloody
murder and secret scandalous sex and
it's up to the reader to decide whose
version of the story is true
a hot d can only show one version of
events it'll be the objective account of
what really happened but we can compare
hotd to the stories in fire and blood to
see if eustace was right or if mushrooms
scandalous tales are true one of the
problems with the game of thrones show
was that the book series it's based on
isn't finished thrones ran out of books
to adapt in season 5 and that's when the
show started getting
a worse in the bomb because i have bowls
danny kind of forgot i don't want it
then brand the broken
unfortunately hot d is different because
the book that it's based on fire and
blood tells the full story of this
conflict from beginning to end so this
time the writers know where they're
going and george martin is much more
involved in hot d than he was in the
last seasons of thrones a hot d is a
fantasy but it's not about black and
white heroes and villains author george
martin loves grey characters who have
both good and evil inside them like in
game of thrones the starks are mostly
heroic and the lannisters are mostly
villainous but they're complicated right
hot d is even more morally ambiguous
viewers will have different opinions
about who the heroes and the villains
are in this story these are complex
conflicted characters who hurt each
other in spectacularly messy ways
they'll be high drama cheating lies
revenge
dark turbulent bloody doings
and we'll cover it all with videos each
week so like and subscribe we're gonna
do a live stream straight after each
episode of house of the dragon every
sunday at about 10 15 pm eastern time on
the alt shift x youtube channel
then we'll make a video explaining and
analyzing each episode like back in the
game of thrones days so subscribe and
press the bell and follow on twitter in
case youtube doesn't give notifications
you might also like to subscribe to the
alt shift x podcast either on youtube or
spotify or your podcast app thanks for
watching and thanks to the patrons
including anna lannis kalmared lame
penguin sporadic sheep kim clark
federico hogwen and ord x
cheers